whether you love it hate it I've never  thought about it chances are some nanny  wants to ban presenting that nanny of  the month runners-up brownsville texas  for banning plastic grocery bags  governor arnold schwarzenegger for  terminating trans fats making california  the first state to ban the stuff that  helps make cookies and other junk food  tastes so good let that cook it down now  but there's only one nanny of the month  and this time it's the diamond bar City  Council for banning live entertainment  at new bars and restaurants that's right  the California city then produced Snoop  Dogg says no rapping singing dancing  jamming spinning or karaoke crooning at  any place that does not already possess  a permit for these disruptive acts  here's to you counsel members way to  suck even more life out of the town  locals already called diamond bore check  back next month for more examples of  busybodies minding your own business